you ready for this you can get dressed
up for nothing
it will kill
[Music]
the soda garame holy geez my name is
Rita Thurman I just turned 50 years old
I'm a scout leader and it's important
for me to be here and be an example for
my Scouts and for my daughter because I
want them to try things even if it's
hard one of the most intimidating and
versatile Japanese pole weapons the Soto
gourami was part of the key Arsenal for
Samurai police during the 17th century
featuring lethal spikes and hooks police
were able to capture violent offenders
from The Distance by using the weapon to
latch onto the suspects stopping them in
their tracks although primarily used in
defense the sharp spikes along with the
spike butt cap made it a menacing and
brutal weapon when in combat today the
Soto garame's devastating use can be
seen in the HBO television series
Westworld
a pair of Viking war axes my name is
Jeremiah bakhaus I am 35 years old I'm
excited but I'm wondering just what they
might have in store during the Viking
Age The Viking war acts evolved from a
common farming tool to a fearsome weapon
of War it's wooden shaft and
single-headed blade made it well
balanced and light enough to repeatedly
deliver Hefty Swings with Fierce
cleaving power the curved blade head
could be used to hook any part of the
opponent's body to forcibly draw them in
closer for a deadly attack the razor
sharp edge could penetrate armor and
bone with frightening ease today Viking
war axis can be seen wielded by
characters and television shows such as
Vikings
[Music]
I have never made anything like this
before I am going to start with my
entangler
super awesome it's time for me to
question
my quench went well
the head of the soda gourami looks
pretty good I'm feeling pretty good
after getting to spend this time on the
weapon
I'm excited to see that I could do it
and I'm excited for my daughter and my
Scouts to see too done pretty much
everything I wanted to do I have time to
do one more thing
stab attack a pumpkin yoink
oh no
oh I gotta fix this
I spent a lot of time on this weapon and
I've broken this thing so I'm just gonna
run back and put whatever kind of crappy
world I can get on it if this doesn't
work I'm screwed
[Music]
I'm excited to get working on these
Viking axes I'm taking the advantage of
having two forges so that hopefully I
can get it done twice as fast so what
I'm going to do now is put this one into
the gas forge switch the other one out
and get them both to the same spot
my biggest concern is that I get them
identical being a blacksmith people want
things that look exactly the same all
the time so not to say that it's easy
but it's a challenge that I'm prepared
for they're identical
I'm Forge welding a high carbon bit into
the body of the ax making a durable Edge
which is historical I'm so nervous I'm
shaking
whenever you do a forge weld there's
always the chance that something could
go wrong if the welds fail I won't have
anything
be doing my
because it got way too thin right up
back here the seams are showing the
welds are not going to hold this is the
worst thing that I could have imagined I
need to start over I'm in big trouble
there's no room for these emotions right
now I have a job that needs to get done
I don't quit until the work is done
yesterday I got my weld set I got my
axes ready time to heat treat both of
them this needs to get done the first
time if this doesn't work I'm in big
trouble
and it's oh yeah still very straight
[Music]
I have two axes thank God Amen
if I need to get my handles ready I
gotta go over the top I got to do
something that the judges haven't seen
I feel good
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
kill test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your sodigarami will do I will take your
weapons and stab and try to snag this
ballistics dummy Rita you're up first
you ready for this hi all right let's do
this
all right let's talk about your Zodi
garami the times you have here
penetrates the hook you have here will
rip this person apart and more
importantly your weapon
kill
Jeremiah shall we do this yes we shall
happening
you can't go from moving
all right Jeremiah your Viking war axis
are razor sharp if that only blew
through the ribs but dug in breaking
through the lungs and Into the Heart it
is fast and light and it will kill thank
you
all right blade Smith it's time for the
strength test the dreaded ice block chop
remember this is not about what these
weapons do to the ice blocks about those
ice blocks due to your weapons and Rita
you're up first you get points of a
theme I mean
you ready it doesn't matter right oh it
doesn't matter
all right
foreign
[Music]
got a little bit more of a bend in this
one tine here
but everything else is pretty much the
way it was going in
definitely held up did his job good job
thank you test the strength and overall
construction of your War axis I'll be
throwing them three times with each ax
into our mock-up of a drawbridge now
hopefully they'll stay tight and right
not loosen up Jeremiah you ready you can
get dressed up for nothing
[Laughter]
so first off Jeremiah they feel like
they weigh the same they definitely
throw the same and having that curve on
the blade allows it to dig a lot deeper
than having a flat Edge but the bottom
line is neither of your blades took any
damage well done thank you
all right blade Smiths welcome to the
sharpness test the Sandman Pierce and
capture
to test the sharpness I will take your
weapon Pierce and try to control this
Sandman relay your first you ready for
this
[Music]
[Applause]
all right we the points you have on your
times here definitely penetrate when you
thrust into that but it doesn't Slice on
the way out or capture as well as it
should
your hook over here did its job overall
it will cut in control
to test the sharpness of your blades see
how they held up I'm going to take your
axes and deliver three shots to these
three fish Jeremiah you're up you ready
time for sushi
well Jeremiah same effect your axes are
bloodied they're now honorable Viking
war axes they are beautiful I like what
you did with the copper relay
not a huge fan and how thin the handles
are to swing it took a little bit more
finger gripping
two very well made axes obviously sharp
well done thank you two blades One
champion you decide the winner forged in
fire war of weapons